Here we are in the SpaceX machine shop.
When Elon Musk founded SpaceX in 2002,
he only had two things going for him.
SpaceX basically consisted of carpet and
a mariachi band. That’s all of SpaceX.
Well, he did have one more thing:
an ambition that knew no bounds.
The sky is not the limit for Elon,
whose mission is to send people to Mars.
On April 20, 2023 - humanity took
one step closer to that dream.
When the world’s largest rocket,
the fully reusable Starship,
attempted to go into orbit for the first time.
Obviously, this isn’t a nominal situation.
Although Starship failed to reach orbit,
learning from failures is Elon's
approach to his career building SpaceX.
And to think he built a rocket
company with just a bachelor’s
degree in economics and another in physics.
Elon, who has Canadian citizenship thanks to
his mother Maye, began his undergrad studies
at Queen's University in Kingston,
Ontario, three hours east of Toronto.
He chose Queen’s over Canada’s University
of Waterloo, which is renowned for its
engineering program, because, as he told
Queen’s magazine, “there didn’t seem to be
any girls (at Waterloo)! I didn’t want to spend
my undergraduate time with a bunch of dudes.”
After two years at Queen’s, he transferred
to the University of Pennsylvania as he
thought attending an Ivy League school
might help him land a job in America.
The land of opportunity when it comes to tech.
Still, degrees in economics and physics
weren’t enough to make him a rocket scientist.
So, Elon taught himself by
devouring these books.
A habit he built as a boy,
reading the entire Encyclopedia when
he was only eight or nine years old.
He also absorbed knowledge
from the industry’s best.
He cold-called aerospace consultant Jim
Cantrell who answered while driving in
his convertible with the roof down.
He thought he heard Elon introduce
himself as an “Internet billionaire”, as
he recalled in an interview with Esquire.
Elon wasn’t quite a billionaire then,
but he did score $180 million when his
financial services company X.com merged
with PayPal, which was bought by eBay.
He then sunk EVERYTHING into three projects:
$100 million into SpaceX, $70 million into Tesla,
and $10 million into solar energy company
SolarCity, which later merged with Tesla.
In 2001, he planned on buying
a refurbished intercontinental
ballistic missile (ICBM) from the
Russians to use as a launch vehicle.
He figured his space ambitions could
start with sending some mice to Mars.
When he went to Moscow to negotiate, the
Russians wanted $8 million per ICBM,
twice what Elon was prepared to pay.
When he countered with $8 million for two rockets,
Jim Cantrell recalled in Ashlee Vance’s biography
on Elon, that the Russians reportedly
“‘said something like, ‘Young boy. No”.
Elon apparently “stormed out of the meeting.”
On the flight home, he broke down the cost
of building and launching a
rocket on a spreadsheet.
He realized a modest-sized rocket
that could carry smaller satellites
and research payloads into space
could be much less than $8 million.
So, SpaceX was born with the goal
of building its own rockets.
It is an understatement to say
starting a rocket company is hard.
But Elon found an ally in the godfather
of rocket science, Tom Mueller.
Tom worked for the large
aerospace company TRW at the time,
which Northrop Grumman later acquired.
He spent weekends building and firing rockets
in the Mojave Desert in California
as part of an amateur rocket club.
The amateur rocket scene was tight,
and Tom got introduced to Elon.
Tom designed the Merlin engine
that powers SpaceX’s rockets.
Merlin revolutionized spaceflight
as it’s designed to be re-used.
Elon understood that the only way to open up space
to everyone was to drastically cut
costs by building reusable rockets.
The Falcon 9 is partially re-usable
as the booster lands back on earth.
Before the Falcon 9, there was the Falcon 1.
The Falcon 1 attempted to reach orbit
for the first time in March 2006.
It lasted only 41 seconds in the air
before crashing due to a fuel leak.
The second attempt the following
year went slightly better,
but the rocket failed to reach
orbit due to a chain of issues
caused by an unexpected bump when the
first and second stages separated.
Third time wasn’t a charm, either, as a
timing error caused the two stages to collide.
Elon had run through all the
money he had set aside for SpaceX.
When you had that third failure in a row,
did you think, "I need to pack this in"?
Never.
Why not?
I don't ever give up. I mean, I'd have
to be dead or completely incapacitated.
He told his employees to keep going.
The then head of talent acquisiition
at SpaceX, Dolly Singh, recalled on
the question-and-answer site Quora, Elon
said: “...we need to pick ourselves up,
and dust ourselves off, because we
have a lot of work to do. Then he said,
with as much fortitude and ferocity
as he could muster…“"For my part,
I will never give up and I mean never,” and
that if we stick with him, we will win.”
“I think most of us would have followed him
into the gates of hell carrying suntan oil
after that. It was the most impressive display
of leadership that I have ever witnessed.”
While Elon tried to save SpaceX,
Tesla was hanging on by a thread.
He joined Tesla in its infancy
after sinking millions from his
PayPal earnings and stepped into the
role as the company’s board chair.
After numerous management changes,
he was left in charge as CEO in late 2008
at a time when Tesla was in serious trouble.
The production of the first vehicle, the
sporty Roadster, went wayyy over budget.
By October 2008, Tesla had just $9
million left to fund the company.
It was hard to convince investors to
fork over millions more during the
worst financial crisis since the Great Depression.
His personal life fared no better; he was
going through a divorce from his first wife,
Justine, with whom he shares triplets and twins.
Elon has said 2008 was the
worst year of his life.
With SpaceX unable to get its rocket into
orbit and Tesla nearly running out of cash,
it looked like one or both of his companies would
die, as he painfully recalled to Ashlee Vance:
"I could either pick SpaceX or Tesla or split
the money I had left between them. If I split
the money, maybe both of them would die.
If I gave the money to just one company,
the probability of it surviving was greater,
but then it would mean certain death for the
other company. I debated that over and over."
It was like having to choose between two children.
Perhaps his difficult childhood
shaped his never-give-up mentality.
He was bullied for years when he was
growing up in Pretoria, South Africa.
One day in eighth or ninth grade, he and
his brother Kimbal were sitting on the
top of a flight of stairs eating when a boy
snuck up behind him, kicked him in the head,
and shoved him down the stairs. Then a
bunch of boys beat him until he blacked out.
The beating damaged his nose so severely
that it restricted airflow, and he later got
surgery to correct his deviated septum.
His life at home was no less painful.
After his parents divorced, Elon opted
to live with his father for a time.
But he told Rolling Stone that his dad
Errol “...was such a terrible human being.
You have no idea. My dad will have a carefully
thought-out plan of evil. He will plan evil.”
Elon found comfort in coding, sometimes
programming throughout the night.
At age twelve, he coded a space-themed
video game called Blastar. A South
African magazine published the
source code and gave him $500.
The game was no marvel of computer programming,
but it did hint at his underlying brilliance.
He turned his science fiction fantasies into
reality when he founded SpaceX at the age of 30.
Despite three failed flight
attempts, an investment from
a venture capital firm made it possible
for SpaceX to attempt a fourth flight.
The future of SpaceX rested
on that fourth launch in 2008.
On September 28, 2008, the Falcon 1 lifted off.
9 minutes 31 seconds after launch,
the rocket…reached orbit.
Sstage separation confirmed!
The success saved SpaceX because
it helped secure a $1.6 billion
contract from NASA to resupply cargo
to the International Space Station.
SpaceX was out of death’s reach. But
Tesla was still within its grasp.
As Tesla was running out of money, Elon
devised a plan to keep his company afloat:
he cut 25% of the workforce and leaned
on friends to cover the weekly payroll.
He managed to scrape together
$20 million, including money he
made investing in his cousin’s data center
startup, which Dell bought the year before.
Investors agreed to match whatever
he was able to get on his own.
This new round of $40 million in
funding saved Tesla on Christmas Eve.
It was the last hour of the
last day that it was possible”
Tesla would endure many more years of pain
after going public in 2010 at $17 a share.
Although the Model S wowed the
world, people hesitated to buy the
luxury vehicle after it came out in 2012.
Elon turned his employees into salespeople
whose job was to convince everyone who put down a
$5,000 deposit to go through with their purchase.
When orders weren’t coming in fast enough,
Tesla said it was temporarily shutting
down its factory for “maintenance” and
kept the real reason secret to avoid spooking
investors and sending the stock plummeting.
Elon’s maneuvering worked.
In 2013, Tesla stunned Wall Street
by posting its first-ever profit.
Elon’s goal had always been to build
a more affordable electric car.
But Tesla simply couldn’t keep
up with demand for the Model 3.
Frankly, we’re gonna be in production hell.
As the saying goes, if you’re
going through hell, keep going.
Elon promised to produce 5,000
Model 3s a week initially,
yet only managed a mere 800 cars a
week in the first few months of 2018.
Tesla was burning cash as it tried to increase
the production of its most affordable car.
Elon says Tesla was about
a month from bankruptcy.
The situation was so critical that he
slept in his factories to save time,
and, he also said it was to
suffer more than his staff.
He told Bloomberg: “Whenever they felt
pain, I wanted mine to be worse.”
The pain eased as Tesla found a way to
claw its way out of danger once again.
Tesla managed to increase production and
turned the corner as it entered 2020.
It has expanded from one factory in Fremoba
nt, California, to factories worldwide.
Tesla delivered 1.3 million cars in 2022.
One of them was my own.
As I drove across Canada last summer,
I couldn’t help but think that one day,
electric cars will be so run-of-the-mill
that they’ll just be called…cars.
I did notice that supercharging stations
across the country were pretty empty.
There was basically no one charging beside me.
Yet charging stations will soon be getting busier.
Many countries, including Canada, have mandated
that all new cars and light-duty trucks
sold be zero-emission vehicles by 2035.
Not to mention other auto companies will now be
relying on Tesla’s charging network, like Ford.
Elon has stressed Tesla must make its cars fully
autonomous in which there is
no human intervention at all.
That’s really the difference
between Tesla being worth a
lot of money or being worth basically zero.
As Tesla engineers work to improve
its full self-driving technology,
it wants to place that technology in a robot.
Optimus perhaps felt like a sideshow
when Tesla first unveiled it in 2021.
However:
Those who are insightful or who listen
carefully will understand that Optimus
ultimately will be worth more than the
car business. Worth more than FSD.
There’s been arguably even more skepticism
over Elon’s plan to ease traffic by
putting Teslas into his own tunnels.
We’re still years away from
seeing whether the Boring
Company’s tunnels will be a visionary
mode of transportation or if there are
too many holes in Elon’s plan - pun intended.
It’s also too early to determine the potential
of Neuralink, which received regulatory approval
in May 2023 to test its brain implant on people.
Neuralink’s chip is meant to stimulate
the brain and help those with spinal
cord injuries control their computers
and smartphones with their thoughts.
I think we have a chance, I emphasize a
chance, of being able to allow somehow who
cannot walk or use their arms
to be able to walk again.
The long-term goal of Neuralink
is to merge humans with AI.
A common theme runs through all his companies.
The dream of freedom from Earth by going to
Mars with the fully reusable Starship.
Freedom from fossil fuels.
Freedom from traffic.
Freedom from the limitations of human biology.
And now Twitter is fighting for
freedom of speech which he felt
was being suppressed under previous leadership.
Twitter has changed its
incorporated name to X Corp,
to move toward Elon’s plan of transforming
Twitter into X, the “everything app”.
That includes making Twitter
a better video experience.
You can now find my full videos
on Twitter, plus exclusive tech
insights I only share on Twitter. Catch me
@Newsthink, or click the link in the description.
Although Elon has been building many
of his companies for over a decade,
their potential is only just starting to emerge.
Regardless of whether he succeeds
or fails, he won’t give up.
He once said, “When something is important enough,
you do it even if the odds
are not in your favor.”
It’s incredible that Elon coded the
Blastar game at the age of just 12.
Although it was impressive then, it’s amazing to
see how far we've come since those
early days of coding simple games.
Well, RAID: Shadow Legends is
an immersive online experience.
When RAID reached out to see if
I was interested in trying out
the game and having them sponsor
one of my videos, I was curious.
I never expected to get this level
of performance out of a mobile game.
RAID: Shadow Legends is a
fantasy-themed role-playing game.
There are loads of powerful
champions. I especially like Elhain.
She’s focused on dealing as much damage
as possible to enemies as possible and
consistently landing critical strikes.
There’s also an epic limited
series, RAID: Call of the Arbiter.
To celebrate, RAID’s adding
some of the new characters
from the series as Champions
you can play with in-game!
The first one is Artak, a mighty Orc warlord,
who is available to everyone for FREE!
All you have to do is just log into RAID
for seven days between now and July 24th.
If you’re a new player, use my custom link in the
description or scan the QR-code on your screen,
and get a free starter pack
with THIS cool in-game-loot!
Thanks for watching. I’m Cindy Pom.